Wake up. AI is here. Open claw moment
happened over President's Day weekend
and it started a month earlier and it
was already acquired for a billion
dollars by Open AI. If you're not paying
attention to this, then you will be left
behind. That being said, I am not here
to fear monger. I'm here to try and
prepare you for what I think is going to
be the biggest shift that's going to
happen in Main Street, not just the tech
businesses. If you're still even
doubting this at all, this is kind of
like newsflash for you. Is that AI will
never be worse than it is right now. And
if you assume any rate of improvement
over any reasonable time period,
learning how to use AI should become
your number one priority, your number
two priority, number three priority, and
your number 10 priority.
And so that's why in this video I'm
going to share some ways to think about
AI and use cases right now that you can
deploy today or by the end of this video
to make significant changes in your
business or start one or how you work
within a larger business cuz I'll show
you how to safeguard your role there,
too, cuz I think it's important. This is
also for my team. So, there's never been
a better time to start an AI first
business to disrupt an existing market
because of all the people in that
existing market are so busy running
their business rather than learning AI
and using words like AI first rather
than actually being AI first. And so the
advantage that you have if you're
starting out is that you have time. But
the thing is is that every single skill
you're able to stack into your ability
to use AI is going to give you
disproportionate leverage over your
competitors. And so having started some
companies in this period of time that
I'm not as public about, we have
companies that revenue per employee
we're talking about in the millions per
year per head because day one we started
that way. Because as much as people want
to say they're AI first, if you have a
big organizational chart of people, it's
very hard one to get people to do stuff
that's new and uncomfortable, which
technology typically is. And then also
because people aren't willing to make
the hard conversations of saying, "Hey,
we automated away this role." Now what
people then think is, "Oh, well, let's
find something else for Danny to do."
But the thing is is that I would
encourage you to raise the bar for the
whole company and the people who who can
meet that new bar get to stay, and the
people who don't, don't. And I'm sorry,
and I know that's that's ugly and that's
harsh, but like this is reality. Right?
And like there was basically let me I'll
play a little thing by Jerome Powell. He
just said this I think yesterday two
days ago
um about how there was zero jobs growth
in the private sector.
>> Effectively, there's zero net job
creation in the private sector.
>> Think about what it is. Nothing the
economy is not doing well.
Is that people are automating jobs away.
All right? Now, again, this video is not
to scare you, but this video hopefully
at least motivates you to take some
action because I think that it won't
happen, and then it will happen very
quickly. So, in game theory, the most
flexible system survives. And so, it's
very much like business Darwinism, if
you will, which is that you have like
it's the people who can adapt are the
ones who will survive. It's not the
strongest or the smartest people, but
the most adaptable. And so, that means
that when there's a change in the
environment, right now, you have to
change. You have to adapt. And learning
how to use the tools is the first and
best way that you can do it. For those
of you who are scared to use AI, first
off, get over it. But beyond that, you
often risk more by not adopting new
technology than by fearing the potential
downside that a small percentage of
people experience. So, some people are
like, "What about AI safety and all
these different things? Like I'm worried
that AI is going to take my credit card
and go spend it." Of course, there's
weird head, you know, edge cases where,
you know, someone gave too many
permissions to an agent and they didn't
have enough guardrails uh installed. But
it's like saying I got hacked on the
internet, so I should never use the
internet again. Is not good reasoning.
Right? And so, why don't more people
adopt AI? Well, the reason is more like
complacency. Right? There's a short-term
cost that you have to incur in order to
learn a new thing. Period. So, it's just
like training an employee. If you're
thinking to yourself, "Well, I I don't
want to train this employee because it's
going to take me time to do that when I
could be doing the work." It's like,
"Yeah, but as soon as you train them,
then they can do the work forever."
Right? It makes sense to do it. But when
you think too short-term, which most
humans do, then you end up losing to
people who can think even a little bit
more long-term. And I will I will repeat
this tweet that I've said before cuz I
think it's so relevant right now. It
takes about 20 hours to become
proficient in any new skill, but people
delay the first hour decades. And so, I
promise you, if you take a weekend and
say Saturday, Sunday, I'm going to sit
in front of this computer and I'm going
to figure out how to do the I'm going to
figure out how to get an agent to do
something for me. All right? If by the
end of the weekend, you haven't
completely built something, but you
actually tore the you know, you tore the
wrapper off, you actually got your hands
in it, your understanding of it will
will increase more than any amount of
articles that you can read that are
fear-mongering and baiting you in,
right? They're just getting it for
reviews and impressions. Let's shift to
like what this actually looks like
within an organization, whether you're
working at one or you're leading one or
you own one, is that you have to stop
thinking in role-based thinking and
start thinking in workflow-based
thinking. So, let's break this down
tactically.
For every hire that you're considering,
you want to write down the four to six
things or eight things or 10 things that
that person actually does does with
their hands and their eyes and like in
their mouth, does stuff, all right? And
then ask whether each of those
activities could live inside of a
workflow instead instead of head count.
And so, the old thinking or the old
paradigm is I need to hire an editor.
The new thinking or paradigm is, what
are these five things an editor actually
does that creates
a video?
And each one of those things should be a
workflow. So, let me just give you a
visual to kind of drive this home.
So, let's say that you have an
organization that looks like this, okay?
Very simple.
Each of these roles
has tasks underneath of them, or at
least they should, right? Of course,
they should.
But, all of these is to organize humans,
not to organize the inputs and outputs.
Because in an organization, if we were
to do something perfectly, we would have
it much more like a manufacturing
business. Now, what does that mean?
Every business at its most basic level
takes raw inputs, adds some special
sauce, and then you get an output that's
more valuable. And so, in a service
business, it means you take raw talent,
you add training and skills, or you put
multiple of these skills together, that
when those skills taken in aggregate are
worth more than any of the individuals
on their own, right? So, if you've got
somebody who knows how to write,
somebody knows how to read, somebody
knows how to record, somebody knows how
to edit, put all that together, all of a
sudden you have an advertising agency.
And somebody else who can buy ads, all
right, you have an advertising agency,
right? And so, but the thing is is that
this is our organizational structure is
to organize communication between human
and hierarchy for decision-making, but
if you had the same rules from the
beginning of how everything should be
created, then all of these little dashes
that I have underneath of here, which
are the tasks that someone does, should
just be organized in a linear fashion
that then create an output.
And so, the key is not saying, "I'm
going to I'm going to I'm going to
automate away this person." You just
have to look at a one layer underneath
of that and say, "What are the 10 things
this person does? Let me see if I can
just automate this one task and this
next task." And if you are that person,
if you're not automating your own job,
you are missing the boat here. Like,
I was talking to a good friend of mine
who is a very good entrepreneur last
night, and he spun up a division within
his company, and the sole thesis or
mission of that business is to put his
much larger business out of business.
And so, if you're not thinking about
that same level of like, "Okay, well,
I'm going to take 20% of my time to try
and put put myself out of a job."
Because the thing is is if you don't
adapt, you will eventually be out of a
job. The question is whether you're
going to be the one who controls that
automation or somebody else will. And
so, let me talk about what the future of
business is going to look like at least
in the medium term. The medium term is
going to be BYOS. So, what does that
mean? It's going to be bring it your own
software or BYOA, bring your own agent
or agents. And so, when you approach a
business, and this means that also
there's going to be tremendous earning
power, even at the employee level, which
is, you know,
uh on by the the gurus of the
internet. But,
if I can approach a business and say, "I
am your entire marketing department." As
a famously maybe we post it up here,
Anthropic has one person in their
marketing department. How is that
possible? Now, of course, they get tons
of PR, there's other things that I think
help them out. But, the big point here
is that they got one guy who's doing it.
Whether that's just marketing lingo or
not, we can be sure that that one person
is still doing a ton of stuff. All
right? And it's not really that person
doing a ton of stuff, they have
automated and created agents that do a
lot of that work for them. And so, all
of a sudden, if you think about the
marketing spend that a business would
allocate for an entire department of
people to get an output, if you can get
that output because of agents that
you've trained on your way of doing
things, then you become very valuable.
Now, can you do that as a contractor and
start an agency around it? For sure. Can
you do it because you want to embed
within a company and get a slice of
equity? Sure. Can you do it just because
you want to get paid more cash? All of
these are things that are available to
you, but they have never been available
until now. Think about what businesses
needs in terms of functions and outputs
and just erase the titleism that exists
in the private market because I do not
think it's going to survive. And so, if
you are that employer that entrepreneur
and you're like, "Okay, well, I want to
I want to do this stuff, right? I want
to I want to actually like use AI. I
want to have agents that do work for
me."
Where people fall off is that they're
not training AI the way they would train
a new employee. And so, they they have
an they have the I was going to say
employee. They have the agent do
something and then the output goes back
and it sucks and they're like, "Oh, this
will never work." Again, I will remind
you, this is the worst that it will ever
be. Number one. Number two. If you had a
brand new employee and then you said,
"Do this task for me." And then they
give something back to you, would you
immediately fire them? Probably not.
You'd be like, "Oh, I just need to train
you more." And if you think, "Oh, well,
uh you know, AI can't do what humans can
do." I really want to break the I want
to I want to destroy this for the people
who don't get it. And if you do get it,
then maybe you need to send this to your
employees or team because this is real.
Humans learn through reinforcement.
Meaning, you do a thing, you get an
outcome, good or bad. If it's good, you
do more of it. If it's bad, you do less
of it. That's how humans learn, period.
And so, when someone says, "Ah, but you
know, it This person has such good
taste." It means that they recognize the
pattern, they communicate that pattern,
and they're rewarded for for for doing
that. And so, they do more and more of
it. And so, they get better and better
at recognizing patterns. Guess what's
really good at recognizing patterns,
even better than humans?
Computers.
Right? And so, fundamentally, you train
a computer the way you should train a
human. The reality is that most people
don't train humans like they should
train computers, and as a result,
they're bad at training. But, one of the
things that if you've ever watched my
channel at all, I'm a big believer in
thinking through operations, thinking
through observable behaviors. Right? And
so, this has actually been an amazing
translation for my skill set into
training AI, because if you take all of
the emotional words out of it, right?
Take all of the ephemeral, take all of
the the intangible out of all of your
words, charisma, make it lighter, make
like all of these words that people use,
and just say like, "What do you want to
have happen?" Which most people do not
do, because they do not define what good
looks like. If you can actually take the
time to define what you actually want,
rather than expecting the other person
to guess and somehow get it right, or
how expect the agent to guess and get it
right, which is really what we're doing,
then all of a sudden you'll be able to
be so much better as an AI trainer,
which is fundamentally what we're going
to be,
so that they can actually do the work
that you want them to do, and do it at
100 times the speed,
um, with no complaints and at a
hundredth of the cost. And so, I'll give
you I'll give you an example. If you're
like, "Hey, I want you like this is a
very simple example." because most
people can understand this use case,
which is like, "Hey, I want you to
write,
uh,
some copy for me." Right? So, it's like,
"Hey, write this email copy for me." If
they write copy and it sounds like AI
slop, it's usually because you didn't
give anything to it besides write words
that are English and correct, and make
it sound like the internet, which is
fundamentally what AI sounds like. It
was trained on the internet, right? And
so it's not the best writing. But if you
say, "Hey, here is 12 rules that you can
never break, and here's 16 writing
samples of mine, and I want you to write
only according to this." You're going to
probably get an output that's probably
like five times as good at that. Now, if
you repeat that loop 100 more times, all
of a sudden you'll have an output that's
that's perfectly trained on the
patterns, except with a person they
forget some of the things you said 16
times ago, um and it takes them time to
go type it, or time to go uh you know,
learn that feedback cycle. And those 100
cycles might take you a year and a half
with a person, but it can take you 100
minutes with AI. Some of you are not
using AI at all. Some of you guys are AI
laggards and are like, "I don't need it.
No one's ever going to replace humans."
And good for you. I love that for you.
Um it'll make it easier to beat you, but
you know, do you.
There are people today
that use fax machines. There are people
today who still count on their fingers.
It doesn't mean that it makes them more
likely to compete. It means that they
are competing and still winning with a
disadvantage, which means that they have
to be so much better in other in the
arenas, right? And so it'd be like not
getting on the internet for your
company. Are there companies right now
that do not have websites and make
money? Absolutely.
Do they make as much as they could?
Probably not. And so this is an absolute
promise to you
is that throughout all of human history
humans plus superior technology beat
humans with inferior technology. It
worked from the Stone Age to the Bronze
Age. It worked from the Bronze Age to
the Iron Age. It worked from the Iron
Age to the Titanium Age, right? Or the
aluminum, which I think my my Aussies
say. Um
to what you can see it very naturally.
And so also I want to give this as a
little bit like a tiny bit of
stress relaxation for you.
As long as it is humans plus tools
against humans with other tools, then
you are still competing against humans.
And as long as that game still goes, you
should feel endlessly confident. The day
that you try to beat the machine, you
will lose. And every time we've tried to
say we like machines will never beat us
at chess, machines will never beat us at
go, machines will never beat us at
insert X, they always do. Uh just like
autopilot on planes, everyone is very
against it. Now, there's going to be
pushback on a lot of AI stuff, but not
because of its function, but because of
people's emotions around it. Real quick,
I'm going to show you the exact 10-stage
roadmap from zero to 100 million plus
that less than 1% of companies finish
I've now done multiple times. And so I
can say with a lot of confidence that
these are the stages as head count
increases that you need to get through.
And I broke each of these down by eight
different functions of the business,
what the constraint feels like, like
what are the symptoms of it when you're
going through it, and then what steps we
actually took to graduate. And we've
done this across software, physical
products,
service businesses, brick-and-mortar,
all of this, and it works. And it's my
gift to you, it's absolutely free. And
so the link's in the description, but
you just go acquisition.com/roadmap,
just enter your info, and it'll spit it
right back to you, all free.
>> Now, in a world of infinite AI labor and
intelligence,
where the cost of intelligence and labor
go to functionally zero, rather the cost
of energy, the last valuable thing that
a human will get paid to do
will be to take risk. And so that is
something that you incur that no one
else can really take away from you,
which is why like I think like money
will exist in the future. It's just that
labor won't have value, and that's where
this gets difficult. So it'll be more
and more difficult to provide value to a
marketplace when you yourself, your
labor, your inherent work no longer has
value when there's a robot that has
infinite intelligence inside of it. It's
stronger, it's faster, and it works for
$200. It works for the price of the
electricity that runs it.
Very hard. And this is again, not to
scare you, but to prepare you for what
is going to come.
And so if you're on Main Street right
now, and you're thinking oh like every
company is going to become a technology
company.
You wouldn't think of yourself as a
technology company but it's like, well,
do you use social media? Do you use the
internet? Do you use email? Do you use
phone? These are all components of
technology that you integrated in your
business. And I would consider this the
last bastion
of where humans play that role. Now,
obviously, GDP is engrossed domestic
product gross domestic product. The
amount that the companies have made per
head count has continued to go up. If we
look at the economy, what are the two
factors that drive output? It's
education, aka skills, and technology,
right? And so, when you have infinite
labor with infinite intelligence,
there's going to be a big explosion
in GDP or gross domestic product.
There's going to be more companies than
ever before. And I also think that
when many roles are going to get
automated away, the amount of businesses
that will bloom from this will be huge.
Um
but I will not say that like I know, and
I don't think anyone does know, but I'd
like, what are the few things that I can
bet on, right? I would like I believe in
a barbell strategy for approaching the
future.
So, what does that mean?
On one extreme, this is the high high
risk high reward. This is I'm fully
incorporating AI in all my stuff. All my
businesses are going to be AI first, AI
native, AI forward. I have to be willing
to have the hard conversations with team
to get them to level up, and if they
don't, I have to be have have to have
even hard conversation that we no longer
need them because we've automated away
the role. I have to be willing to do
that because guess what? You might not
be willing to do that, but there's going
to be a startup that just doesn't have
to have that conversation, that is going
to already be automating those roles,
and they will beat you.
That's the high risk high reward side.
On the other side, it's what are the few
bets, and this is Jeff Bezos' frame,
which is what are the few bets that I
can make that I believe won't change.
What things will absolutely still exist?
I believe that humans will still have
bodies, at least in the near to medium
term. So, I think health-related things
will absolutely exist.
So, healthcare, fitness-related stuff,
all that stuff will
consumables, food, supplements, all that
stuff will still exist. I think in a
world where there's way more robots and
way more work getting done for humans,
what will humans have? If we look at
human history, we have more of one
thing, which is leisure or downtime. So,
what do we fill our leisure or downtime
with? Entertainment. I believe
entertainment is going to boom. It's
already big. It's gone It's continued to
grow as a percentage of GDP, and I think
it will explode because I think people
have more time on their hands, and
entertainment is typically very cheap.
And so, if you want to like you can make
a full motion picture now. And And
there's this period of time where the
prices have not adjusted to the to the
cost basis associated. And so, you can
make some viral social media videos and
get huge amount of PR for a movie that
you made entirely with AI
and make $100 million, $200 million.
And the beauty of that is it's all
margin.
And you can absolutely do that.
So, why don't people do it? Because
people are afraid to take to take
action. But is that is that there?
Absolutely. I'll also give you something
that uh will make some people
uncomfortable, that's just an absolute
reality of business in general, is that
if you actually really want to know what
the bleeding edge of like what's going
to happen with anything is in terms of
tech as it incorporates in business. I
know this is going to sound at least
sound a little bit off off-putting for
some people. Look at porn.
Whatever porn adopts first eventually
makes its way down. So, what if what if
we already seen happen in the porn
industry? You've got AI avatar girls who
are, you know, people are spinning up
these AI avatars. They have an army of
100 girls or guys, I don't know,
whatever your flavor is, right? Or
aliens. I mean, again, whatever you
want.
Where people And I'm not saying good or
bad, I'm just saying pure economics,
right? Where they don't have to deal
with the drama associated with They
don't have to film them. They don't have
to get the They just make videos. They
render them. They send them out. They
have chats that is really just a chatbot
that's going back and forth Someone
that's been trained on 10,000
porn-related conversations. And people
pay for them. And so,
what do I believe is going to happen in
the future?
I believe that humans will need a place
to live.
I I they'll need food to eat.
I believe that they will have things
they need to do with their time for
entertainment. I believe those are
industries that I would absolutely say
like these things will not change. Now,
which one wins? Who knows? But those
industries I think will exist.
And then I'll give you my hell in a a
hell in a handbasket frame. So, what
does that mean?
If there's a world where everything goes
to then doesn't really matter.
Right? And so, I have to walk myself
back off of the the apocalyptic angle of
like, "Okay, well, if all of these
things eventually, you know, disrupt and
there's no and there's a permanent
underclass and no one has any money
uh and there's you know, only a select
few who actually leaned into technology
to acquire all the wealth in the world.
Um if that were to happen, you know,
it's all going to be anarchy. Maybe, I
don't know, but I just prefer to exist
in a world where, you know, I I'm hoping
for the best, preparing for the worst.
Um but I am absolutely hoping for the
best. And I think in the hell in a
handbasket world, none of it will
matter.
Prepare for sunshine and rain.
Just be an all-weather type of person.
And I think if you do that, you'll give
yourself the best chance at succeeding
whatever the next season looks like. And
I'll give you a final kind of thought
thought experiment that might be helpful
for you. So, I read this on a a Brian
Johnson post from Blueprint, if you've
heard of him. He's the he's the
longevity guy. He said, "What
what people do not realize is that
they've been training their entire lives
to swim.
And you think that you can swim in all
types of weather and you got to become a
better and better swimmer, right? And
you know, there's there's waves crashing
and you're like, you know, you go from
in a in a pool or a lap pool to a lake
to eventually you're you're swimming off
the coast to eventually you're free free
ocean swimming from border country to
the next border country, right? It's a
crazy levels.
He said, "But the change that's about to
happen is a phase shift
where you're swimming, but then all of a
sudden the water boils
and now you're in gas because the water
all evaporated and you're flapping your
arms. It doesn't matter how good of a
swimmer you are. The fundamental physics
of the environment will have changed.
And so, that is the change that we're on
the precipice of. Now, hopefully this
was not doom and gloom because I I I
actually see this tremendous opportunity
because
humans are slow to adapt in general.
So, what does that mean? First off, if
you're watching this, you're already
probably ahead of most people anyways
cuz most people just exist. They put
their put their head in the dirt.
There's so many people over age 50 that
are like, "I'm done for this shit." And
guess what? They got all the money.
And so what's really interesting is that
all the people got all the money are
going to quickly realize that it's going
to go somewhere else, which is not to
them because they did not adapt. So,
that's a big opportunity.
There's also huge opportunities
obviously in going to regular businesses
and automating portions of their work.
But when I said humans are slow to
adapt, it also means their price
sensitivity is also slow to adapt.
Meaning if people are used to paying
$2,000 a month for something, that
embedded in that price is the typical
cost of labor.
And so if you can
still charge that $2,000 price for
whatever it is, right? And instead of it
costing you $500 a month, it costs you
$50 a month or $5 a month, the margin,
number one, that you can earn is
tremendous. But second, and more
importantly, the amount of operational
leverage you have, meaning the amount of
people per dollar of additional revenue
you need to to to create, goes down
dramatically. As in, one person now can
bring millions and millions in revenue
in.
It becomes much easier to scale because
one of the biggest costs of scaling is
just the coordination between humans.
And so
what I would encourage you to do is
you're like, "Okay, I heard all this
stuff. I feel motivated to do something.
What should I do?" This is what I want
to ask you to do. Write down a list of
what you do do every day. And I'm saying
at the most granular level. You respond
to emails. You respond to Slack
messages. Maybe you make content. Maybe
you you make ads. You run ads. There's
You have to separate these out into
individual What's the task, right? Don't
think it don't think it chunked up.
Don't think I make you know, I run ads.
It's like, yeah, there's a lot of stuff
underneath of that, right? You make
campaigns. You set budgets. You analyze
results. You make the creative. You
write copy. There you you you test
different landing pages, you test
different headlines on the pages.
There's lots of things that are
underneath of that bucketed term of like
I run ads, right? Take all of the tasks,
and then look at those tasks, and take
the first one, and put it into AI, and
say,
"Help me automate this."
"What steps would you take?"
It'll give you a list. And then take the
first thing on the list, and do it. If
you get stuck, here's a little pro tip.
Screenshot your screen, and put it in,
and say, "What do I do now?"
And it'll tell you. And then screenshot
the next screen, and say, "What do I do
now?" And it'll tell you.
Like everyone now, here's this Here's
just the craziest thing of all is
everyone has an AI tutor at their
fingertips
that you're just not using.
So,
with that, this is the type of stuff
that we that we were obviously actively
working on inside of our ACQ Advantage
community. So, if you are a
million-dollar-plus business owner,
we're talking about stuff that we're
doing right now every day inside of ACQ.
And obviously, we have an AI product
that we've been training for years now.
We also have like AI salesmen that we've
been training. We've got a lot of stuff
that we've been doing, keeping more or
less behind, you know, behind closed
doors, if you will, capitalizing on
opportunity, if you will.
But, you can go check that out. I'll
have a link below the thing. Maybe it's
on the screen, whatever. But, with that,
peace and blessings be upon you and your
bloodline,
and I wish you the absolute best, and I
hope you are in the permanent upper
class,
and not permanent underclass in the
world that comes.